you mentioned books
is there
bertrand russell and denial of death by
anders becker is there
books that pop into mind that
like had an impact on you my favorite
novel is middle march
middle march i remember like i was
listening to a podcast i was listening
one of your podcasts where he said where
where your guests said the two greatest
novels of the 19th century
were uh were brothers karamazov and uh
what was the other one he mentioned i
don't remember
as well or no i think i was both
i might have been i don't remember maybe
the but anyway but i would say middle
march is up there middlemarch like
presents an entire world and it's
written by a woman uh marianne evans who
took the pen name george eliot
who
you feel
virginia woolf said it's the only
english novel written for grown-ups
you feel the genius in her sentence it's
like the pressure of her intellect in
her sentences it's a beaut it's a
wonderful wonderful book i love it
pressure of her intellect yeah you
really do
i also love i love soul bello especially
herzog but but it's a very different
kind of uh
of thinking person's novel i read a lot
of mysteries um and a lot of other kinds
of fiction and literature but
in terms in terms of the books that most
you mentioned one of them which is
viktor frankl's man search for meaning
and i also really really love heschel's
the sabbath i think it's a beautiful
book
very sh it's very short book just as
frankl's book is
what do you take from the math search
for meaning what what do you take of a
human being in in the worst conditions
being able to
um
non-dramatically
yeah find little joys find
find beauty
and it's
it's what i said before about judaism's
advice to younger people is that it
matters if you believe that something
matters
you have enormous resilience
it's meaninglessness that is the
greatest threat to a decent life when
people are like deeply depressed
whether it is chemical depression or
what they feel like is this is all
meaningless yeah and
and meaning now obviously
chemical depression calls in part for
chemical means but
but meaning is the it's the great
antidote
we can talk about what kind of meaning i
mean there are kinds of meanings that
are awful but
but meaning is the great antidote to
a sense that life is just nihilistic and
purposeless and
and to that destructiveness that i think
is
too common
yeah so maybe maybe the heroic action
in nazi germany in the holocaust and the
camps is the
even not the action but just the
realization that every life matters so
here's this
really wonderful story that hugo grin
who was a who was a rabbi in england
i don't know like 15 20 years ago used
to tell he grew up in auschwitz
he was a child there and he was with his
father and it was hanukkah
and you're supposed to light the candles
and his father took the margarine ration
and used it as the oil to light the
hanukkah candles and hugo said was
scandalized and he said that's our food
and his father said what we have learned
my son
is you can live for three weeks
without food you can live for three days
without water but you can't live for
three minutes without hope
you